I've been warning you about today for months,
July 30th, the day that we knew we would get
our estimate of the second quarter GDP number
of the United States.
We received that number this morning.
And it is historic.
It's historically bad.
I mean, why did Donald Trump tweet today that
he wants to delay the election?
I believe that the GDP number is part of it.
In addition to the collapsing polls, the United
States economy shrank by the biggest amount
on record in the second quarter.
This year, annualized second quarter GDP was
down thirty two point nine percent.
Thirty two point.
The economy contracted annualized by roughly
a third in the second quarter.
Now the expectation was to be down 34.
So being down 33 is like slightly less bad
than the expectation, but a historic, disastrous
number.
Now we know why.
It's very easy to say, listen, it's not Trump's
fault, it's coronavirus.
OK, but the Trump administration has failed
in terms of the corona virus response.
So the health numbers, meaning cases and deaths,
are worse than the numbers had to be.
Just look at other countries and the economic
numbers are also worse than they had to be.
The big areas of reduction in GDP were not
shockingly consumer spending and the personal
consumption category.
And remember that this is just an estimate.
We get more precise numbers about another
month out.
So this is an estimate on July 30th.
We're expecting the sort of more more fine
tuned numbers right around August 30th.
And who knows what will be going on by then?
With coronavirus.
Now, meanwhile, new jobless claims have also
gone in the wrong direction.
New jobless claims are up for the second week
in a row to one point forty three million
new claims.
This is the 19th straight week with more than
one million people losing their jobs.
Of the 19 weeks new jobless claims, it was
like six point six million that first week
or the second week.
And then they've been declining for 15 weeks.
Now things have turned around.
And new jobless claims have started to increase.
And the unfortunate reality is that it could
get much worse if states have to keep continue
pulling back.
If we continue to see cases rise.
Deaths have spiked, then we'll talk about
that next.
I believe states are going to have to pull
back and the numbers are going to once again
get worse.
We were we were told in April, May, by June
1st, June 15th, there will be very few new
cases and barely any deaths.
There will be a break between wave one and
what is expected to be a second wave in the
fall.
We're not getting that break.
We are actually when we got down to 20000
new cases a day, things started opening irresponsibly
in some states, more responsibly in others.
And we are now seeing the effects of that.
And the next thing I want to talk about is
the numbers and the trajectory that these
numbers could very soon take.